quick clarification i'm sorry to
interject lee then when you say that
life is abundant in the universe are you
not referring to the observable universe
sure i think it's abundant in the
observable universe and we'll learn how
to find it and i think actually
frustratingly we probably will find
techno signatures
you know hints of them and not just
hints hints that brian and i will look
at the data we'll look at the
uncertainty the error bars your point is
taken i haven't forgotten it's a very
good point brian and we will then go
well the balance is fat here is like we
will be it is possible remotely to get
data
uh um squeeze down those areas and know
for sure there's alien technological
life elsewhere in the universe we could
do it okay and don't let nasa and other
people say it's not we can do it we can
detect the higgs boson if we can look at
the cosmic microwave background we will
be our fine technological um signatures
but we but we need a better theory which
i am trying to introduce it might not be
the right one but i've got a feeling
it's going in that direction but to
answer the question where all the
technology is there's a number of
answers to that but i want to say
something quite profound
if time really is a thing and let's say
time is a commodity and at the beginning
of our local
universe where the laws are now i'm
going to define time and this is going
to be like
i mean i'm not a very good singer but
this is going to be like brian hearing a
really bad singer
and he's like breaking physics but here
i'll try
at the origin of the universe there was
some kind of singularity which basically
we seem to be we were kind of one
quantumly connected one particle let's
say and through that causal
aperture
the
the the the size of the electron the
what you know the the there's charge to
mass ratio of the electron the
gravitational for all the forces would
produce or all that was produced there
right in that single point because
people say the laws and all the
constants the constants are just
contingencies right and so so we have
that
and then from that that process that
point in time where the universe
expanded
and i think
again brian has the history of the
universe down like i think if i remember
i'm studying you that all the hydrogen
in the universe was made in the first 20
minutes or something which is just a
mind-blowing uh kind of fact and it's
true than the big bang theory tv show
exactly that's a great so now you've got
this stuff right
in time
now the reason is the clock is ticking
now at that time you don't have enough
states in the universe
to actually produce life it's kind of
cool basically you actually they're the
fermi paradox and i'm saying i have to
qualify this because i'm stealing this
idea i agree with it from sarah walker
so i you know i'm not very good well i
should be clear i should steal more
ideas but but she's convinced me and i
and i also think it's true it's a
natural consequence of assembly theory
the fermi paradox is not about the fact
that we that we don't see the aliens
just
the we're looking back in time and at
that time the universe didn't have the
ability to produce technology so it's
like a fermi filter and think for a
second it's like oh [ __ ]
we looking back in time the universe
didn't have the ability to produce
technology at that time
we have to look in a different way
actually i'll push back again uh just to
say that there was an epic in the
universe where you didn't need a hard
rocky planet to sustain uh room
temperature liquid water and that was a
time about you know eight billion years
ago when the universe curt was at the
temperature above zero degrees celsius
which is uh you know about 50 degrees
warmer than it is in toronto or glasgow
i'm just trying to make you guys jealous
you'll visit me here in san diego in
january sometime
so the universe could have liquid water
for millions billions of years until it
become frozen water um and so actually
no there there's a reverse filter there
there's sort of a system no no no no
that's that i have to push back that's
quite nice but i'm saying
something very
profound in terms of the the number of
states available i don't care how much
water is available who cares what i care
about is a combinatorial state space
remember i'm not a chemist here i'm a
mathematician but in the states so
you're right with kurt but kurt the
amount i'm going to have sarah on my
show next week but but uh and i'll ask
her about this but the the i mean is it
galaxy is one galaxy sufficient uh sp
estate space to create technological
life obviously this is what we're this
is what i think i think the answer is no
right and i what we just let's just keep
going with this arguing there's let's
just make a conjecture i don't know
right but isn't it interesting you've
got a smaller volume in the universe
time is the thing so you're not going
back and forth so you have to
um there's this causal chain of events i
don't know how delicate it plays into
your argument really nicely what
sequence of events have to happen in the
first 20 minutes the next 200 million
years the next two billion years to
prepare the universe to be able to
metabolize elements fusion right produce
objects that can then have enough
structure enough surface area for
selection to occur
over a period of time so you might not
you might need stability of a few
hundred million years with a certain
gravitational force but let's not add
that on i'm just saying hey wouldn't it
be cool if the fermi paradox is actually
just evidence the universe had not yet
had enough causal history to produce
life
we popped up as soon as it could so we
should like ah okay let's now i'll say
let's just make this very simple for
ourselves and say life in the universe
kind of started to emerge when life
let's say there's nothing special about
earth
happen quickly
so life was possible in the universe
about four billion years ago and so what
we now do is we reframe our observations
and we look around i'm just making this
up so new idea i had today thanks to
sarah's idea and brian's question and
yours did you come up with the
metabolized elements because that's a
cool line i'm going to steal that yeah
yeah i just made it i wouldn't steal it
from sarah i would steal it from you no
no no i you could steal that from me i
just made it up just now um and so
you've kind of got this idea that
basically
um you're creating this infrastructure
for causation
that that allows you to go a bit further
and and so what happens i don't know i
mean if only we had an astronomer who
understood how to look back here like if
you redrew the line said right we're
going to now restrict ourselves looking
for a 4 billion
year old light cone and we look at the
exoplanets other objects how does that
reframe
the search for life or intelligence so i
mean there's lots of ideas there so the
conjecture is
there is a filter that is just the
universe wasn't capable of producing
life until a particular time now it is
then technology and then how does that
go on and that plays into redoing our
error bars in the in the in the in the
fermi paradox and in the drake equation
and also i hide my only shield brian is
i don't see anything magic on earth
so it's probably possible elsewhere
because okay so that's a great point let
me interject because you're
it's difficult to interject without
interrupting i'm sorry lee no no it's
all good your podcast uh you you beat us
in come on yeah okay great you use many
ands and so i'm not sure if the sentence
is complete or if it's run-on and i
don't want to seem rude okay so brian
you just made a great point what is an
example of some other phenomenon that
happens on earth that doesn't occur
elsewhere in the universe so water waves
maybe one well there's maybe water waves
and mountains atmosphere okay so
given that it sounds like there's
nothing special about earth's life so
why are you isolating earth's life
as saying well that's unique
on example
if these plot you know it's like they
want to have their you know primordial
soup and eat it too you know they want
to say it's ubiquitous these processes
are generic
and yet not seeing it you know it's more
than just a fermi paradox and i will
push back on sarah gently with respect
uh because i love her work uh
but but the fact is you know though
those are almost borderline you know
kind of ideas that i hear from
intelligent designers too you know which
is that the laws of physics the state
space of the laws of physics the
constants of nature the mass of the
electron the uh fine structure constant
all the things you talked about are
implied um those you know are can be con
conflated with you know some kind of low
entropy state instantiated by a designer
i don't want to talk about that except
to say that i don't think that that
pushes the pro that filter is very fine
cor fine grain and i will talk to her
about it but i do want to say that again
generically speaking these processes are
ubiquitous so therefore the
non-observation like that should go into
the fermi paradox not that the universe
is large uh that these processes are uh
you know we we just detected uh you know
we've detected uh helioseismological
effects on other stars we've detected uh
the existence of you know what we think
are continental you know patterns so
tectonic you know potential potentiality
for tectonic activity which we do
believe some believe are but all this
kind of pushes things back like one of
my big um gripes against the seti
institute which i know and love and i've
had jill tarter and seth sostak and i've
donated to them um and and i've spoken
there but you know i started to get a
little bit suspicious when a couple of
years ago they started shifting away
from the
existence of live techno signatures to
extremophiles here on earth i don't
think that necessarily answers or gets
to the heart of the question certainly
not of extraterrestrial intelligence to
know some smokey uh that deep smoker has
uh you know has bacteria cyanogenic
bacteria or or prokaryotic type whatever
that's interesting but it's not aligned
with eti that's what i care about i mean
yeah let's cut the bs what we really
care about is making contact as eric
says you know if you could short circuit
and get to the laws of the 25th century
and get to the other side maybe we would
pass the great filter you know as it's
been called and protect ourselves and i
i happen to think that might be wishful
thinking uh but i commend eric for
working on a theory to perhaps unlock
some of these uh some of these portals
as he calls it um but but nevertheless i
i think again
is there you know is there a rubric that
you and i could agree on or or disagree
on and i think the audience would like
to know are are there um in other words
if you hear you know there's been an a
credible account lou elizondo past
guests on kurt show um you know has
claimed you know really very very uh
high credence levels in the existence of
extraterrestrials capable of
technologically navigating across our
galaxy correct me if i'm misstating or
overstating and the basic point as a
physicist cares about um and that is um
you know non god bless you lee non god
bless you or whatever you got darwin
bless you darwin bless you when you
sneeze i have to say that uh but but
he's mainly so can we by laws of
chemistry physics assembly whatever can
we say no we actually shouldn't have the
cr you know credulity that lee that that
luis has uh and instead we should he
should update his priors based on these
following chemical physical mathematical
laws is there a way that we can do that
for them i i think so i think there's a
way to do this let me just answer a
little bit and then i'll explain
assembly theory so yeah i think what i
think is likely to happen
if
i mean i don't know i mean like i have
no
i'm a curious i would i think it's
likely that we if life exists in the
solar system
some chemical lice life um i'm i'm
optimistic that we'll go and find some
evidence with some
you know sending dragonfly to titan the
mass spectrometer on it we're going to
hopefully go to europa and so on
we're going to hopefully do origin of
life on earth and when i succeed but
don't get the nobel prize i can write my
other book you know i can get brian to
do it forward in it and all that because
we chemists hate it and what we're
likely to do i think is we should be
looking for technology technological
techno signatures
you know i mean i think that the
exoplanet we're going to detect an
exoplanet of oxygen on it and so we
found life and that's just going to be
baloney